papa
après
on va
oh
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
heureux de vous retrouver à ce mardi
cinéma vous avez été fidèle à jeudi
cinéma la dernière j'espère que vous
serez fidèles à notre mardi cinéma et
bien vous allez retrouver des éléments
nouveaux et des éléments anciens parmi
les éléments anciens il ya la présence
de vedettes que nous aimons et ce soir
j'ai le plaisir de vous dire que gérard
depardieu est avec nous mais les
candidats et bien les candidats ce sont
des représentants d'établissements
scolaires de si les clubs
d'établissements scolaires et j'ai
derrière moi
sainghin quatre garçons et une fille du
lycée turgot qui joueront avec gérard
depardieu et enfin s'il n'y a pas que
gérard depardieu il y a aussi son
complice de la chèvre il ya pierre
richard qui est avec nous merci pierre
d'être avec nous ils s'adorent clés de
la gamme et pierre richard jouera pour
un lycée qui est derrière lui qui
derrière nous c'est le lycée jacques
decour quatre garçons parce que j'étais
au lycée jacques decour c'est vrai il ya
50 ans alors le tirage au sort a bien
fait les choses puisque tu va
représenter ce soir le lycée jacques
decour est allé c'était un élève
brillant
le jeune pierre richard non j'étais
foutu à la porte mais ça j'ai quand même
été et bien en tout cas nous sommes
heureux que vous veniez tous les 2
baptisé notre émission mardi cinéma car
vous êtes tous les deux les
représentants là du grand succès de noël
du grand succès notre ami webber c'est
la chaîne oui oui oui les français c'est
pas si mal mais même demande une suite
after shave pouvait
et adducteurs francis des avec la chance
à ça fuse francis veber nous avait dit
avant que le film sorte qu'il souhaitait
à tous les metteurs en scène le couple
richard depardieu francis oui mais ça
c'est ça s'est vérifié ont dû répondre
c'est mon film à vous protéger des
retombées francis nous éclaircir on se
déchire en cours de la soirée d'ailleurs
bien entendu
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue à mardi
cinéma à mardi cinéma un peu différent
présenté par daniel ceccaldi un grand
comédien qu'on aime tout ce qu'on adore
même mais aussi un homme qui sait
regarder et apprécier un homme plein
d'humour et d'intelligence il aura
l'oeil du professionnel madame qui sait
regarder apprécier les dames aussi comme
je ne suis pas assez présomptueux pour
oser présenter ce monument la télévision
qu'un mardi cinéma
j'avais demandé à la chaîne de deux
mètres près de moi une jeune femme de
préférence blonde grande et un peu bêta
et je suis heureux de vous présenter
guide a noté mère qui comblent
complètement mes voeux mardi cinéma donc
un peu différent avec un nouveau jeu et
un concours un jeu monsieur cinéma où
s'affronteront sur ce plateau de
cinéphiles extrêmement érudit un
concours pour vous qui portera sur sept
films choisis par l'invité un invité
unique mais de taille daniel de taille
et de poids de poids je le présentais un
cane immense plaisir c'est claude
chabrol
vous êtes super laura je suis heureux de
vous recevoir et je suis heureux vous
soyez venu le jour de la rentrée des
classes
oui bah je vous étiez un bon élève eh
ben je n'étais pas mauvais j'ai retrouvé
un vieux butin comme ça on disait du
bien - oui vous êtes il a dormi au
phoque relatifs du pied vous étiez
peut-être même un élève sage beaucoup de
tueries et vous êtes rattraper après il
faut toute façon ça le regarde pas il
serait enfin je n'étais pas très bien
changer dans mardi cinéma les têtes le
décor le jeu reste un des piliers de
l'émission et bien l'actualité
cinématographique daniel oui l'actualité
cinématographique c'est la constante de
mardi cinéma
nous allons vous présenter comme nous le
faisions toujours l'actualité de la
prochaine quinzaine en espérant en
espérant que cette actualité va vous
inciter à aller beaucoup possiblement
non
bonsoir à tous et bonsoir à tout soyez
les bienvenus dans ce théâtre de
l'empiré ou soir on se passer des choses
étonnantes puisque nous avons des
acteurs superbe qui vont venir nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants
vous aurez bien entendu des jeux
auxquels vous participerez au moins par
la pensée et puis des cadeaux qui vous
concerne un caméscope pour un
téléspectateur à caméscope pour un
spectateur du théâtre de l' empire bien
entendu et pour l'équipe victorieuse
cela va de soi nous allons accueillir
ceux qui seront nos vedettes ce soir et
en même temps les concurrents voici tout
d'abord pour l'équipe à
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter bruno
cremer
cher maître vous en prie mais non ils
commencent
si vous voulez bien vous installer ici
merci infiniment il sera aidé de son
complice et ami jean luc bideau
nollywood c'est au lycée hollywood ce
soir à hollywood
ici s'il vous plaît jean-luc voilà
l'autre équipe et j'ai cru constater au
départ qu'il régnait une certaine
animosité entre les deux équipes qui
sont prêtes s'entre déchirer pour
l'équipe b jacques bayle
boussemart jacques viguier vous même
demandez-leur la gentillesse de vous
asseoir ici voilà s'il vous plaît est
également concurrente de l'équipe b
arielle dombasle alors là mes enfants
pauli
j
vous demandez vous asseoir à côté de moi
je ne suis pas fou bon et puis bien
entendu tu veux nino que joshua sang
cette caméra là où celle là et même
davantage peut-être celle là quand même
y aller mieux
nous allons parcourir ensemble tout au
long de la soirée l'actualité
cinématographique